well here we go again yet another Donald
Trump muslim-majority nation immigration
ban has been signed by executive order
we had the first attempt total disaster
ruled illegal unconstitutional by a
federal court White House officials said
in private that they believed it
actually damaged Donald Trump's
presidency the total disaster that was
the first attempt at this and the
administration has now rolled out a new
travel ban with slightly softer
provisions but it's still in the broader
scheme of things some of the most
extreme immigration policy that we've
ever seen here is the executive order
signed by Trump called the executive
order protecting the nation from foreign
terrorists entry into the United States
here's DHS secretary John Kelly saying
just how great this is going to be for
everybody today's executive order which
President Trump signed this morning will
make America more secure and address
long overdue concerns about the security
of our immigration system we must
undertake a rigorous review and are
undertaking a rigorous review of our
immigration vetting programs to increase
our confidence in the decisions we make
relative to visitors and immigrants that
travel to the United States yeah what a
ringing endorsement super excited guy
there anyway attorney general jeff
Sessions and Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson were also at this press
conference nobody took any questions the
problem is of course that a leaked
document last week made clear from DHS
itself that the first immigrant ban
wouldn't have been an effective means of
stopping terror the order that Donald
Trump sign yesterday bars entry to the
US by people from six predominantly
Muslim countries the same list from
attempt number one except Iraq has been
removed so we're talking about Iran
Libya Somalia Sudan Syria and Yemen the
White House figured out that if you ban
people from Iraq it might hurt our image
over there as we fight Isis and removing
Iraq from the list
actually defense secretary Madison's
idea but Donald Trump is threatened to
add other countries to the list
including Iraq if the White House
doesn't fields they're cooperating with
the United States enough a major point
aside from whether you agree with this
type of policy is that the list doesn't
include any country from which anyone
has come and committed terrorism on US
soil although undoubtedly Iran which is
on the list major major exporter of
terrorism around the world including to
my birth country of Argentina the list
still excludes countries with terrorists
where Trump has business ties like Saudi
Arabia and Egypt that's separate from
whether this is a policy whose type
makes sense generally and I believe that
it really is the major provisions of
this policy are that almost no new
immigrants from the updated list of
countries will be allowed to enter the
US for at least the next 90 days the
order also got rid of the permanent ban
on Syrian refugees but almost no
refugees from any country will be led
into the US for the next four months
here is a little bit a couple different
things from the travel ban number one
the Secretary of State shall suspend
travel of refugees into the United
States and suspend decisions on
applications for refugee status for 120
days after the effective date of
disorder subject to waivers Donald Trump
can renew those bands when they expire
the order also caps refugees at 50,000
per year that's less than half of what
was allowed under President Barack Obama
there's a section of the order that
actually seems almost like it's
resentful and defensive about the court
having about numerous courts having
blocked the first order where the order
says executive order 13 769 the previous
one did not provide a basis for
discriminating for or against members of
any particular religion that order was
not motivated by animus toward any
religion the reality is that during the
campaign Trump said plainly he wants to
ban Muslims from the you
they also wrote in language that keeps
with their accusation is that terrorism
and immigrant crime don't get enough
publicity in media this reads more like
a political rally speech than it does an
executive order on immigration another
quote from it that i'm referring to to
be more transparent with the american
people DHS will collect and make
publicly available the following
information the number of foreign
nationals in the US who have been
charged with terrorism related offenses
and the immigration status of foreign
nationals charged with major offences
the order doesn't explain how our
already rigorous vetting system is going
to be ramped up this leaves room for
officials to just sort of come up with
something later saying quote the
Secretary of Homeland Security shall
conduct a worldwide review to identify
whether and if so what additional
information will be needed from each
foreign country to adjudicate an
application by a national of that
country for a visa admission or other
benefit in order to determine that the
individual is not a security or public
safety threat so differences from the
first band to this band this order will
make more exemptions for people from
band countries then the first order did
this order also exempts current
permanent residents and visa holders
from trying who are trying to re-enter
the country this should prevent those
situations where you had permanent
residents and visa holders originally
from the listed countries who were out
at the time the first order was signed
getting stuck at airports trying to come
back in it also gets rid of that clause
about preferential treatment for
Christian so the administration has made
this band somewhat lighter more narrow
presumably hoping to avoid the backlash
from the first order a recap of what
this order does new immigrants are
barred green card holders from the
countries listed are exempted from the
band diplomats from the listed countries
are allowed all refugees
from the countries are barred dual
nationals are allowed into the US and
Iraqi nationals are allowed in which
Iraq not on this list was on the first
list going to be phased in over two
weeks instead of in one day my reaction
to this path is exactly what I feared
after the last immigration ban was
destroyed by the legal system which is
they passed the hundred and twenty
percent crazy version that was taken
down it was it was by numerous courts
determined to be illegal
unconstitutional they now come back with
something that is ninety eighty five
percent of the original band but maybe
it's one hundred percent of what they
genuinely wanted to begin with and no
doubt there will be backlash but there
will be less backlash and the trump
administration probably thought about
trying to appeal one of the Court's
decisions to the Supreme Court to see if
they could upheld this and make it make
it seem constitutional in some way yeah
but it clearly wasn't I mean it
prioritized Christians and without these
exemptions it was clearly
unconstitutional I think with the
provisions that they've updated it will
be upheld because I think this is within
the power of the president I've been
reading legal opinions from legal
experts on the left right and center and
indeed it appears as though most of the
legal issues presented by the first one
are addressed here but that it's really
too early to tell right we don't yet
know what legal issues may come up a lot
of this is sort of like NSA surveillance
or TSA passenger screening techniques if
we believe that these provisions would
be super effective at fighting terror or
crime we would be having a different
conversation which is do the ends
justify the means what's the legality
etc many people would understandably
still say no but much like NSA bulk
surveillance much like TSA passenger
screening techniques we know that they
aren't that effective so what are we
even arguing about it is merely optics
and political theater especially because
this is a temporary ban and has been
marketed as such sense Trump proposed
this idea in December of 2015 of rolling
out some sort of Muslim ban
I mean if it was effective you'd think
you'd have to make it so it lasts a
longer period of time and he could keep
extending it yes indeed but clearly I
mean there is just not going to work we
have numerous reports including from
agencies that will be involved in the
enforcement of this band saying this is
not an effective means of fighting
terror well I guess in the Trump Barrow
we don't really trust our institutions
anymore we know the FBI and CIA hey
they're part of the fake news problem
maybe the report from DHS which is going
to be part of enforcing this also is
fake news I'm obviously joking around
we'll see ultimately what legal
challenges surface